[Musique]
en fonction de l'âge des jeunes
il ya différentes activités possibles
pour un job d'été pour les mineurs çà se
cantonne à deux trois domaines maximum
parce que on peut travailler à partir de
16 ans mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué après pour les majeurs c'est
tout type de domaine
on va repartir de leur cv 6 en 1 qui est
plutôt scolaire et essayer de mettre en
avant certaines choses qui peuvent être
intéressantes par exemple dans
l'animation tout ce qui est en rapport
avec garde d'enfants baby sitting et
dans le commerce e 6 en fait un stage de
découverte en troisième les expériences
extra scolaires ou extra est étudiante
comme le sport les activités
associatives sont des atouts aussi qu'on
peut mettre en avant dans sa candidature
on n'a pas toujours d'entretien
d'embauché pour un job d'été mais c'est
bien de s'y préparer surtout quand on
n'a pas l'habitude d'être face à un
recruteur pendant un entretien le les
arguments qu'on apporte sont importants
mais aussi la façon
de s'exprimer le langage non verbal sont
aussi des points qui sont à travailler à
prendre en considération la personnalité
être naturel détendu et avoir un petit
peu de répartie ça se travaille
même si on est timide ça peut se
préparer